no reason in 2008 not all right so this
is the talk that I gave in 2008 that
probably changed my game my book you
know came from it a lot of attention
came from it it was just one of those
talks moment sometimes tipping point
whatever the heck you want to call it
things happened more things is happening
with this talk because it ended up on
Ted then you know a lot of people expect
that brand and it puts in a different
place and it's been a huge thing and a
lot of people have seen my TED talk
people think I've been to dead and talk
they didn't have to know it's like best
of web attend does but here's why I'm
making this video and wasting your time
if you zoom in here the latest comment
and there's been a lot of comments
thanks mark you know what works nobody
ever sees you again so the latest
comment is kind of interesting and as
you can see I'll show you this by the
way there's a big thesis of mine you can
see a lot of people have commented and
you can see that I have commented to
them so really important to engage with
your comments online in them just a
little side [ __ ] it's like a side deal
of bubonic just gave you that a little
bit but anyway more importantly
interesting so the Packard's might talk
I'll link up this talk and that's a lot
of you've heard it and says
uncomfortable this is mister plus key
Big Ups to him I appreciate his thoughts
says I'm comfortable with this all pro
persuasive philosophy of if you really
want it and work hard you don't get it
eventually
it's much like a religion because the
opposite is true that if you failed even
when the economy collapsed or you
contracted cancer or thugs smashed your
business or whatever
well that's because you didn't work hard
enough or didn't you know pray hard
enough someone has to clean bathrooms
someone has to dig ditches I find this
interesting because
you'd really listen to my talk and this
is something I've heard brought up from
this talk and I guess the title of this
blog post is practicality versus praying
I'm not saying and please don't get it
twisted
mr. Pulaski or anybody else and I didn't
say then that talker ever any time in my
career and I'm not sure why I wanted to
go out there but what's happening in
2008 and now much more in 2010 is not
that if you pray hard or if you were
really hardly crush it until 5:00 in the
morning that it's gonna happen when I'm
talking about and what I'm outrageous ly
passionate about and when I think about
on a daily basis whether it's consulting
for my brands or for its you at home
right now who loves the Smurfs and
Smurfs it up it's not about the fact
that if you work hard enough you'll get
it it's a fact that it's practical to
have that back it's like not everyone I
want to be frickin LeBron that's watch
LeBron James is I wanna be you know
freaking you know Mark Sanchez and be
the quarterback of the New York Jets
but I can sit here all I want even if I
trained football all day or if you see
it it's not going to happen however in
the business world building a business
in 2010 we're back in 2008 we have
at-bats we have a chance it's kind of
like this I'm not gonna be the Jets
quarterback but if this was the business
world that sports was that way I'd be in
New York right now and in Jersey or
Cortland trying out for the New York
Jets we all have the opportunity because
the cost of entry is practical you know
that person you were talking about that
has to clean bathrooms and dig ditches
you're absolutely right mark plus key
you are 100 [ __ ] thousand percent
right that somebody has to do it
however he looks different Johnny who
had a dig ditches in 1973 when he got
home exhausted at 7:30 spend time with
the family you know do something run a
house dad tired
what had you he had no shot of doing a
sec
job because what he was kind of done
even if you have a passion burning from
his chest like fire at 8:30 what was he
really gonna do now the fact that can he
brewed up a computer and I understand
the finances maybe not everybody can a
computer I mean there is a look I
understand barriers but the fact that he
can dip up his computer and start it and
create content become part of the
community go to search that Twitter to
talk about his helling Dodgers that he
loves start a tumblr blog or WordPress
blog and start doctors talk calm and do
it and pound it and his voice can get
out there and then the viral nature or
the word-of-mouth economy that we live
in that there's a prayer that if he
wants to stay up to two o'clock in the
morning instead of grabbing the beer
just watching the game if he wants to
and I'm not saying he has to because
there's plenty good things and digging
ditches coming on spending time of your
family and then resting you can play
this game in any way you want but the
practicality to come home and build a
business after hours today is the
difference this is a praying this is
opportunity